es mayor ahora en 2016
de lo que era hace 125 años, en 1890,
y ha subido en casi cada década
en el intervalo de 125 años.
Esto plantea una paradoja.
Nuestras máquinas hacen cada vez más el trabajo por nosotros.
¿Por qué no hacen nuestro trabajo redundante y nuestras habilidades obsoletas?
¿Por qué hay todavía tantos puestos de trabajo?
(Risas)
Trataré de responder a esta pregunta esta noche,
y en el camino, voy a decirles lo que esto significa para el futuro del trabajo
y los desafíos que la automatización plantea y no plantea
para nuestra sociedad.
¿Por qué hay tantos puestos de trabajo?
En realidad, hay dos principios económicos fundamentales en juego.
Uno tiene que ver con el genio humano
y la creatividad.
El otro tiene que ver con la insaciabilidad humana,
o la codicia, si lo quieren.
Voy a llamar al primero el principio de junta tórica,
que determina el tipo de trabajo que hacemos.
El segundo es el principio de no-conseguir-lo suficiente,
que determina el número de puestos de trabajo que hay hoy.
Vamos a empezar con el de junta tórica.
Los cajeros automáticos,
tuvieron dos efectos compensatorios sobre el empleo cajero bancario.
Como se esperaba, reemplazaron muchas tareas de cajero.
El número de cajeros por sucursal se redujo en cerca de un tercio.
Pero los bancos descubrieron que también era más barato abrir nuevas sucursales,
y el número de sucursales bancarias aumentó en alrededor de un 40 %
en el mismo período de tiempo.
El resultado neto fue más sucursales y más cajeros.
Pero esos cajeros estaban haciendo un trabajo algo diferente.
Como su rutina, tareas de manejo de efectivo, disminuyó
se volvieron menos cajeros
y más vendedores,
estableciendo relaciones con los clientes,
resolviendo problemas
e introduciendo nuevos productos
como tarjetas de crédito, préstamos e inversiones:
más cajeros, un trabajo más exigente cognitivamente.
Hay un principio general aquí.
La mayor parte del trabajo que hacemos
requiere una multiplicidad de habilidades,
y cerebro y fuerza,
experiencia técnica y dominio intuitivo,
transpiración e inspiración en palabras de Thomas Edison.
En general, la automatización de algún subconjunto de esas tareas
no hace innecesarias a las demás.
De hecho, se hacen más importantes.
Aumenta su valor económico.
Déjeme darles un ejemplo claro.
En 1986 el transbordador espacial Challenger
explotó y se estrelló contra la Tierra
menos de dos minutos tras despegar.
La causa de ese accidente resultó ser,
una junta tórica de caucho de bajo costo en el cohete
que se había congelado en el área de lanzamiento la noche anterior
y que falló catastróficamente momentos después del despegue.
En esta empresa multimillonaria
esa sencilla junta tórica de caucho
marcó la diferencia entre el éxito de la misión
y la calamitosa muerte de siete astronautas.
Una metáfora ingeniosa para esta trágica entorno
es la función de producción junta tórica,
llamada así por el economista de Harvard Michael Kremer
después del desastre del Challenger.
La función de producción junta tórica concibe el trabajo
como una serie de pasos entrelazados,
eslabones de una cadena.
Cada uno de estos enlaces debe ajustar para que la misión tenga éxito.
Si alguno de ellos falla,
la misión, o el producto o el servicio,
se viene abajo.
Esta situación precaria tiene una implicación sorprendentemente positiva,
que es que las mejoras
en la fiabilidad de cualquier eslabón de la cadena
aumenta el valor de mejorar cualquiera de los otros eslabones.
En concreto, si la mayoría de los eslabones son frágiles
y propensos a la rotura,
el hecho de que su enlace no sea tan fiable
no es tan importante.
Probablemente otro se romperá de todos modos.
Pero, si todos los demás eslabones se vuelven robustos y fiables,
la importancia de su enlace se vuelve más esencial.
En el límite todo depende de ella.
La razón por la que la junta tórica era crítica
para el transbordador espacial Challenger
es porque todo lo demás funcionó a la perfección.
Si el Challenger fuera el equivalente espacial
de Microsoft Windows 2000...
(Risas)
la fiabilidad de la junta tórica no habría importado
porque la máquina se habría estrellado.
(Risas)
Esta es la generalización.
En gran parte del trabajo que hacemos, somos las juntas tóricas.
Sí, los cajeros automáticos podrían hacer ciertas tareas de manejo de efectivo
más rápido y mejor que los cajeros,
pero eso no hizo superfluo a los cajeros.
Se aumentó la importancia de sus habilidades para resolver problemas
y sus relaciones con los clientes.
El mismo principio se aplica si estamos construyendo un edificio,
si estamos diagnosticando y cuidando a un paciente,
o si estamos enseñando una clase
a un salón lleno de estudiantes de secundaria.
A medida que nuestras herramientas mejoran,
la tecnología aumenta nuestro apalancamiento
y aumenta la importancia de nuestra experiencia
y nuestro juicio y nuestra creatividad.
Y eso me lleva al segundo principio:
Nunca consigues suficiente.
Pueden estar pensando, bien, junta tórica, vale,
dice que los trabajos que hace la gente, serán importantes.
No pueden ser realizados por máquinas, pero aún se tienen que hacer.
Pero no me dice cuántos puestos de trabajo se necesitarán.
Si se piensa en ello, ¿no es autoevidente
que una vez que se tiene algo suficientemente productivo,
se está trabajamos en acabar un puesto de trabajo?
En 1900, el 40 % de todo el empleo de EE. UU.
fue en las granjas.
Hoy en día, es menos del 2 %.
¿Por qué hay tan pocos agricultores hoy en día?
No es porque estemos comiendo menos.
(Risas)
Un siglo de crecimiento de la productividad agrícola
significa que ahora, un par de millones de agricultores
pueden alimentar a una nación de 320 millones.
Es un sorprendente progreso,
pero también significa que solo hay pocos puestos de trabajo tóricas en agricultura.
Claramente, la tecnología puede eliminar puestos de trabajo.
La agricultura es solo un ejemplo.
Hay muchos otros.
Pero lo que es cierto acerca de un solo producto o servicio o industria
nunca ha sido verdad para la economía en su conjunto.
Muchas de las industrias en las que trabajamos ahora,
salud y medicina,
finanzas y seguros,
la electrónica y la informática,
eran pequeñas o casi inexistentes hace un siglo.
Muchos productos en los que gastamos un montón de dinero
acondicionadores de aire, vehículos utilitarios deportivos,
computadoras y móviles,
eran inalcanzablemente caros
o simplemente no se habían inventado hace un siglo.
A medida que la automatización libera nuestro tiempo,
aumenta el alcance de lo que es posible,
inventamos nuevos productos, nuevas ideas, nuevos servicios
que dirige nuestra atención,
ocupa nuestro tiempo
y estimula el consumo.
Es posible que algunas de estas cosas sean frívolas
--yoga extrema, turismo de aventura,
Pokémon GO--
y podría estar de acuerdo con Uds.
Pero la gente las desea, y están dispuestas a trabajar duro para ellas.
El trabajador promedio que en 2015
quiera alcanzar el nivel de vida promedio en 1915
podría hacerlo trabajando solo 17 semanas al año,
una tercera parte del tiempo.
Pero la mayoría no elige hacer eso.
Están dispuestos a trabajar duro
para cosechar la recompensa tecnológica que está disponible para ellos.
La abundancia material nunca ha eliminado la escasez percibida.
En palabras del economista Thorstein Veblen,
la invención es la madre de la necesidad.
Ahora...
Si aceptan estos dos principios,
el de junta tórica y el de no-conseguir-lo suficiente,
estarán de acuerdo conmigo.
Habrá puestos de trabajo.
¿Significa que no hay nada de qué preocuparse?
Automatización, empleo, robots y puestos de trabajo,
¿todo se va a cuidar de sí mismo?
No.
Ese no es mi argumento.
La automatización crea riqueza
por lo que nos permite hacer más trabajo en menos tiempo.
No hay ninguna ley económica
que diga cómo utilizar bien esa riqueza,
y de qué vale la pena preocuparse.
Consideren dos países,
Noruega y Arabia Saudita.
Ambas naciones ricas en petróleo,
es como si tuvieran el dinero que sale a borbotones de un agujero en el suelo.
(Risas)
Pero no han utilizado esa riqueza igual de bien para fomentar la prosperidad humana,
a los seres humanos.
Noruega es una democracia próspera.
En general, sus ciudadanos trabajan y juegan bien juntos.
Está normalmente numerados entre primero y cuarto
en el ranking de felicidad nacional.
Arabia Saudí es una monarquía absoluta
en la que muchos ciudadanos carecen de un camino para el progreso personal.
Es típicamente el puesto 35 entre las naciones en la felicidad,
que es baja para un país tan rico.
Solo a modo de comparación,
EE. UU. está típicamente por el puesto 12 o 13.
La diferencia entre estos dos países
no es su riqueza
y no es su tecnología.
Es sus instituciones.
Noruega ha invertido para construir una sociedad
con oportunidades y estabilidad económica.
Arabia Saudita ha elevado el nivel de vida
mientras frustra muchos otros esfuerzos humanos.
Dos países, ambos ricos,
no igualmente bien.
Y esto me lleva al desafío que enfrentamos hoy en día,
el reto que plantea la automatización para nosotros.
El reto no es quedarnos sin trabajo.
EE. UU. creó 14 millones de puestos de trabajo
tras lo hondo de la Gran Recesión.
El reto es que muchos de esos puestos de trabajo
no son buenos puestos de trabajo,
y muchos ciudadanos no pueden calificar para los buenos empleos
que se están creando.
El crecimiento del empleo en EE. UU. y en gran parte del mundo desarrollado
se ve como una barra de pesas
con el aumento de peso en cada extremo de la barra.
Por un lado,
tienen alto nivel de educación, empleos con salarios altos
como médicos y enfermeras, programadores e ingenieros,
marketing y gerentes de ventas.
El empleo es robusto en estos puestos, crecimiento del empleo.
Del mismo modo, el crecimiento del empleo es robusto en muchos de baja calificación,
empleos de baja educación como servicio de alimentos,
limpieza, seguridad,
ayudas de salud en el hogar.
Al mismo tiempo, el empleo se está reduciendo
en muchos de educación media, salarios medios, trabajos de clase media,
como la producción de cuello azul y posiciones operativas
y de cuello blanco puestos de ventas de oficina.
Las razones de esta contracción en el medio
no son misteriosas.
Muchos de esos puestos de habilidades media
utilizan las reglas y procedimientos bien entendidos
que pueden codificarse en software
y ejecutarse por ordenadores.
El reto que crea este fenómeno,
lo que los economistas llaman la polarización del empleo,
es que retira peldaños en la escala económica,
reduce el tamaño de la clase media
y amenaza con hacernos una sociedad más estratificada.
Por un lado, un conjunto profesionales altamente educados y muy bien pagados
haciendo un trabajo interesante,
por otro, un gran número de ciudadanos en trabajos de baja remuneración
cuya principal responsabilidad es velar por la comodidad y salud de los ricos.
Esa no es mi visión de progreso,
y dudo que sea la de Uds.
Pero aquí es una noticia alentadora.
Hemos enfrentado transformaciones económicas
igualmente trascendentales en el pasado, y las hemos pasado con éxito.
A finales de 1800 y principios de 1900,
cuando la automatización eliminaba un gran número de trabajos agrícolas
--¿recuerdan el tractor?--
los estados agrícolas enfrentaban una amenaza de desempleo masivo,
una generación de jóvenes ya no se necesitaban en la granja
pero no estaban preparados para la industria.
Al aumentar el desafío,
tomaron el paso radical
de requerir que toda su población juvenil
permaneciera en la escuela y continuara su educación
hasta a la avanzada edad de 16 años.
Se llamó el movimiento de la escuela secundaria,
y era algo radicalmente caro hacerlo.
No solo tuvieron que invertir en escuelas,
sino que esos niños no podían trabajar en sus oficios.
También resultó ser una de las mejores inversiones
que EE. UU. hizo en el siglo XX.
Nos dio la más hábil, la más flexible
y la más productiva mano de obra del mundo.
Para ver lo bien que funcionó, imaginen tener la fuerza de trabajo de 1899
y traerlos al presente.
A pesar de sus fuertes espaldas y buenos caracteres,
muchos de ellos carecerían de las habilidades básicas de lectura y cálculo
para cualquier cosa, salvo los trabajos más mundanos.
Muchos de ellos estarían desempleados.
Lo que este ejemplo pone de relieve es la primacía de nuestras instituciones,
muy especialmente nuestras escuelas,
en lo que nos permite recoger la cosecha
de nuestra prosperidad tecnológica.
Es tonto decir que no hay nada de qué preocuparse.
Es evidente que podemos lograrlo mal.
Si EE. UU. no invierte en sus escuelas y en sus habilidades
hace un siglo en el movimiento de la escuela secundaria,
seríamos menos prósperos,
con menor movilidad y, probablemente, la sociedad mucho menos feliz.
Pero igual de absurdo es decir que nuestro destino está sellado.
Eso no está decidido por las máquinas.
Ni siquiera decidido por el mercado.
Es decidido por nosotros y por nuestras instituciones.
Empecé esta charla con una paradoja.
Nuestras máquinas hacen cada vez más nuestro trabajo.
¿Por qué no hacen superfluo nuestro trabajo,
redundantes nuestras habilidades?
¿No es obvio que el camino hacia nuestro infierno económico y social
está pavimentado con nuestros propios grandes inventos?
La historia ha ofrecido en repetidas ocasiones una respuesta a esta paradoja.
La primera parte de la respuesta es que la tecnología aumenta nuestra influencia,
aumenta la importancia, el valor añadido
de nuestra experiencia, nuestro juicio y nuestra creatividad.
Esa es la junta tórica.
La segunda parte de la respuesta es nuestra inventiva sin fin
y deseos sin fondo,
que nunca tenemos suficiente, nunca tenemos suficiente.
Siempre hay un nuevo trabajo que hacer.
Ajustar el rápido ritmo del cambio tecnológico
crea problemas reales,
que se ve más claramente en nuestro mercado de trabajo polarizado
y la amenaza para la movilidad económica.
El aumento a este reto no es automático.
No es sin costo.
No es fácil.
Pero es factible.
Y aquí una noticia alentadora.
Debido a nuestra increíble productividad,
somos ricos.
Por supuesto podemos permitirnos invertir en nosotros y nuestros hijos
como hizo EE. UU. hace cien años con el movimiento de la escuela secundaria.
Podría decirse, que no podemos permitirnos no hacerlo.
Ahora, pueden estar pensando,
Profesor Autor nos ha contado una tierna historia
sobre un pasado distante,
el pasado reciente,
tal vez el presente, pero probablemente no en el futuro.
Porque todo el mundo sabe que esta vez es diferente.
¿Verdad? ¿Es diferente esta vez?
Por supuesto, esta vez es diferente.
Cada vez es diferente.
En numerosas ocasiones en los últimos 200 años,
académicos y activistas han dado la alarma
que nos estamos quedando sin trabajo y haciendo obsoletos:
por ejemplo, los Luddites a principios de 1800;
el secretario de Trabajo de EE. UU. James Davis
a mediados de la década de 1920;
el ganador del Premio Nobel el economista Wassily Leontief en 1982;
y, por supuesto, muchos estudiosos,
expertos, tecnólogos
y figuras de los medios hoy en día.
Estas predicciones me parecen arrogantes.
Estos oráculos autoproclamados están en vigor diciendo,
"Si no puedo pensar en lo que la gente va a hacer para trabajar en el futuro,
entonces, yo y nuestros hijos
tampoco van a pensar en eso".
No tengo las agallas
para hacer esa apuesta contra el ingenio humano.
Miren, no puedo decir lo que la gente va a hacer para trabajar
un centenar de años a partir de ahora.
Pero el futuro no depende de mi imaginación.
Si yo fuera un granjero de Iowa en el año 1900,
y un economista del siglo XXI teletransportado a mi campo
dijera: "Oye, adivina qué, agricultor Autor,
en los próximos cien años,
el empleo agrícola va a caer de un 40 % de todos los puestos de trabajo
a un 2 %
debido solo al aumento de la productividad.
¿Qué crees que hará el otro 38 % de los trabajadores?".
Yo no hubiera dicho, "Oh, haremos esto.
Desarrollaremos aplicaciones, medicina radiológica,
clases de yoga, Bitmoji".
(Risas)
No hubiera tenido ni idea.
Pero espero que habría tenido la sabiduría de decir,
"Huy, una reducción del 95 % en el empleo agrícola
sin escasez de alimentos.
Esa es una increíble cantidad de progreso.
Espero que la humanidad encuentre algo notable para hacer
con toda esa prosperidad".
Y, en general, diría que se logró.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)